today we're talking about how you're
playing an old build of battlefield 2042
how ea is thinking about renaming the
fifa series and when you're finally
going to be able to see some halo
infinite ranked multiplayer my name is
devonte chisholm and you're watching
gamespot news
so the battlefield 2042 beta is
available now for ea play and pre-order
customers but unfortunately plenty of
people have already reported a variety
of bugs and other issues part of it
comes down to the fact that the beta
represents the game in a month's old
state the nature of game development
means that beta clients are often well
behind where the game is currently at
and that holds true for battlefield 2042
but not to worry dice is on it they've
published a list of known issues with
the battlefield 2042 open beta some of
which have already been fixed for the
full game's release in november but for
the time being i guess have fun just
shooting people with your fists
battlefield 2042 looks more like metroid
[Laughter]
in other ea news the company has said it
might end its partnership with fifa for
its future football games ea sports gm
cam weber said in a blog post that ea is
exploring the possibility of renaming
its fifa series as a part of its rights
agreement negotiations with fifa ea's
deal with fifa to use their name is good
through 2022 so ea and fifa have about a
year to get a deal done or not weber
explained in the blog post that ea has
separate licensing deals with over 300
groups beyond fifa that give the company
access to more than 17 000 athletes on
700 plus teams in 100 stadiums and
covering 30 leagues around the world in
essence weber is saying ea does not
strictly need to work with fifa on
future games because it has rights
agreements in other places this
situation sounds similar in some ways to
what's happening with ea's college
football series the franchise is
returning but it won't have the ncaa
name instead ea worked out a deal with
the collegiate licensing company to get
the rights to player names stadiums and
other real world elements
but alright let's talk about shooters
again the halo infinite multiplayer beta
seems to have gone over well with fans
but one common piece of feedback is that
fans want to know when 343 will reveal
details about the game's ranked and
competitive play well thankfully that's
coming up soon while 343 is apparently
dropping a blog post with the sandbox
multiplayer and competitive insights
team and we're getting new gameplay that
shows off halo infinite's competitive
settings this should all be available
sometime next week
[Music]
alright now it's time for what you all
are really here for some money news the
mpd group released a new report on
thursday that reveals that time and
money spent on games in the us jumped by
35 over the past six months the uptick
was driven in part by people in the 45
to 64 age bracket which includes
so-called baby boomers according to
mpd's matt piscatella this growth in the
45 to 64 age group is made up in part by
lapsed gamers who return to games during
the pandemic for entertainment and to
stay connected to friends and family
but alright time to get creative hit the
comment section and let me know what ea
should rename the fifa series and i mean
get really creative not crazy just
really creative i'm gonna read all of
them every single one of them
[Music]
you